you want the last word go ahead I'll
give it to you King Shawn
why is result on a real black person
that's the type of black people that
wear backpacks and shave off a mustache
and all of that stuff
rasaan do you carry be honest for son do
you carry a backpack I don't carry a
backpack now what is it with you King of
All Blacks why are you the example of
not a real black man I think his idea of
a real black man is the stereotype and I
don't think I said that
Brisson why don't you admit you want to
wear a backpack i Swan there to be
better than the stereotype that's my
only issues might just be better than
the stereotype he's trying to say
because he knows I don't like the word
live is it possible that King of All
Blacks is jealous of you because you
made all your own money in other words
your father didn't leave you a bunch of
my dad's awesome everybody was just man
come on
when your baby was born did you carry
that thing over your chest with the baby
I gotta interrupt for mine say it is
okay he goes Bassam
did you have a dad and then I'm just
gonna say that I've known worse on for
six years we do the wrap-up show
together every day where Sun is a very
real person he never tries to act like
anybody he isn't
I feel like King lived in all along King
lives in fear every day that he's not
gonna he has to see what everybody is
doing so he can act like what he thinks
people want him to be he's not real
you're like I'm telling you you're a
fraud you're not real
they're not real to yourself we gotta
stop talking to King like this cuz you
know he had a nose job
all right King upon those jobs
you